they kill time for Greg's animal friends
where the panelists are hot but the
animals are hotter Charles you go first
so I've got the uh
dogs playful playful dogs video the the
classic Chihuahua versus the pit bull oh
wow you know it's like the attitude look
at that it's like
I just love these Chihuahuas I really do
they don't know their own size they
really don't they're just like look at
this I'll bust your ass get out of here
get out of here
and the pit bull is like so cool look at
that oh just I love it I love it I just
I love Chihuahuas and the pit bulls got
patience out of this world yeah well we
didn't see the rest of the video
I'll give you a hint it was sort of like
the ones that introduced this
exactly Pitbull's gotta eat too yes
all right Jim what do you got I got the
orangutan yeah yeah he's uh he's got the
butterfly in his mouth
oh it looks like you know almost like uh
an old jackass clip you know yeah eat
the butterfly but I'm thinking maybe not
eating maybe it's a hot day and he's
like I just use it as a fan
fair that butterflies get all the get
all the love yeah I love Gutfeld he's
being eaten alive
those are desperation flies you should
spend more time in caterpillar weight
room yes or maybe he's just sick of
bananas he's like I've had I I gotta eat
something else don't you feel like maybe
there's a toxin coming off those wings
sort of like cocaine I mean look at that
look at this
chilling like yo this is exactly that's
a butterfly this is how you get monkey
pox
it was spread by the butterflies read
your literature
there aren't there's no literature I
just made that up Kennedy
Greg this is uh not so much a fun animal
video as a cautionary tale because we
all know dolphins are the rapists of the
sea oh my God this is not a fish out of
water
squirming for dear life
this is a cruel fraternity prank gone
wrong this is horrible that woman is
helpless to his prehensile penis which
is what dolphins possess
this is horrible this dolphin has been
de-platformed my God
looks like he's deep platforming right
now
oh my God he got her on D platform
didn't he whoa holy not okay not okay
well I'm not going to Sea World
that dolphin wants to see your world
I'll tell you
or rocket
look ma no hands yeah they didn't show
that in flipper all right Tyrus what do
you got lizards no in the spirit of your
video uh some of my turtle eggs hatched
and it was their first feeding and this
guy he was just going to town now he
ripped this dude in half when he bit him
That's How Strong their jaws are the
funny part is is that while this fish
he's still breathing why he's being
eaten alive is his little buddy keeps
checking on him his little orange fish
keep swimming up like you're okay bro
you're okay you're okay bro cause I
can't feel my legs like you're
delusional you never had legs
am I going to be okay and then his
little buddy starts eating them too wow
well it's good to see Mitch McConnell
getting around
are turtles smart
uh some are Terrapins are smart
Terrapins what's the difference brain
structure size Evolution Terrapins are
smart like they can recognize you know
your name and all that kind of stuff
alligators are pretty smart too a
Maryland student yeah yeah I think I
think dolphins are smart for humping
that girl
dolphin misconduct is a thing it happens
a lot I did not put carp oil on my
bikini bottoms I swear to you Jim
all right I think we're done here so
let's do something else up next a dog
who let her rip and ruin their trip hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else